the results were highly anticipated in
the west bank city of Ramallah where
Yasser Arafat is buried many have long
suspected he was murdered they were
hoping the scientists in Switzerland
would provide them with proof because he
bores the key findings are that we have
evidence of an abnormal quantity of
polonium and led in these samples don't
official you to try and explain where
this polonium and this led came from we
hypothesized that a source of polonium
had been ingested by the victim and we
modeled this result the team said
although the results reasonably
supported the poisoning hypothesis the
evidence was not conclusive and they
could not unequivocally say what had
killed Arafat many Palestinians accused
Israel of being behind his death an
allegation Israel denies an Israeli
government spokesman dismissed the
investigation which involved opening
Arafat's tomb and said it was more soap
opera than science but the Palestinian
Liberation Organization says there's no
other credible suspect about a little
more either amidst an international
inquiry committee should be formed to
investigate this and to find who
committed this crime against the martyr
Yasser Arafat because only Israel had an
interest in killing him yeah Maria
thought you were a killer but in Israel
the media have speculated a power
struggle within the Palestinian
leadership might have been behind
Arafat's death